[Applaudissements]
des cabinets les plus à droite qui est
connu Israël ça coalition comprend
notamment le parti du sionisme religieux
et force juive connues pour leur propos
antipalistiniens et leur position
favorable à l'annexion d'une partie de
la séjour Dany et le parti Noam
ouvertement anti LGBTQ on a ici dans
Monsieur
Gilly coude qui entame son sixième
mandat à la tête du pays se dit
déterminer à rétablir la gouvernance la
paix et la sécurité des citoyens
d'Israël
le porte-parole du Hamas lui lance
néanmoins un avertissement clair ce type
de politique pourrait mener à
d'éventuelles escalade sur le terrain ce
que craint aussi le professeur Grèce
amer qui s'oppose au nouveau
gouvernement s'il y a une chose qu'ils
ont vu c'est effectivement la
multiplication des implantations juives
dans territoires ainsi Jordanie et
c'est leur but numéro 1 ici israéliens
les avis sont mitigés à des quarts de
leur nouveau Premier ministre
cette dame aimerait lui laisser une
chance puisqu'il aurait déjà fait ses
preuves habillé des égards
coalition au pouvoir former d'ultra
orthodoxes n'est pas suffisamment
représentative de la population
en territoire palestinien on dit avoir
peur d'être réprimé par Israël
inculpé pour corruption dans plusieurs
affaires le chef du lyco de maintenant
âgé de 73 ans avait été chassé du
pouvoir en juin 2021 son retour entre
autres été salués par le président russe
Vladimir Poutine et le président
américain Joe Biden qui continue pour sa
part de soutenir la création de deux
états en Israël ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal